why are you whispering Oh what come on
be cool
no it's not cool you just told me you
can't get me out of here you can't get
you out me get me out
happy birthday Matthew ha ha ha
festive day what are you 32 they have my
records they know it's not my birthday
this is a special cake that I made for
you in fact if I were to file this cake
that file it under D for delicious in a
file cabinet file you put a file and a
cake no no that's preposterous that's
something in C on one of those cartoon
shows I totally put a file in the cake
something I saw in one of my cartoon
shows how am I supposed to break out of
prison with file and take take it out ah
huh
and at night by your window Oh Andy
Dufresne was free okay I knew the
sisters would never have their way with
you right but let's Shawshank that's a
fake movie that's impossible
thank God the lawyer brought him a file
anything you thought you were just gonna
walk in here and hand me a cake you're
just gonna hand me a cake huh about the
glass I thought about that okay
cake is mostly air what
nope nope you're an idiot you're you're
an idiot you're an idiot you're an idiot
Am I yes you're an idiot listen to me do
you have a better idea on how to get a
file into that side I'm gonna go water
on this side every time I come to visit
you on that side of the glass they
search everything my briefcase my mouth
and as if there was a place on a human
body that you could wait no no no no no
don't even think it
I don't even want it I don't even want
the file dude come on
give me five minutes